I took the top five things that I think
people attack you on in my opinion
misquote you on and I thought maybe we
could take five minutes for each one
five or six minutes for each one and
that way each time someone says well Sam
Harris wants to nuke the middle east or
sam Harris wants to racially profile
Muslims or whatever it is you or I or
anyone that's clear minded can just send
a link and so here it is in five minutes
I have to read a book you don't have to
watch a three-hour interview here it is
I think the number one thing that people
say about you is that when you say Islam
you mean all Muslims right right so take
it away yeah so the claim is that I
generalize about Muslims and this is
incredibly ironic because half the time
in that film our clip was spent where I
was talking about statistics and poll
results and percentages and the certain
percentage is jihadist and then there's
a wider circle of Islamists and then
there's a wider wider circle of
conservatives and so I never generalize
about the Muslim world and insofar as we
have good data on the numbers of people
who subscribe to various beliefs that
I'm always looking at those data and so
and everything I say about the problem
of Islam and Islamism takes as its area
of concern first and foremost the people
living in the Muslim world who are
living under the shadow of if not that
the boot of theocracy so you know women
and gays and freethinkers and public
intellectuals and atheists people who
email me saying they're afraid they're
their mother and father will kill them
if they knew they were an atheist for
instance and there's nobody who I who I
celebrate more than Muslim apostates and
muslin and and true reformist Muslims
like my co-author on this new book Majid
Nawaz who have taken just heroic risks
to say critical things about the faith
in a context where it's much more
dangerous to do so than the context and
where you and I live and so you know if
I were a Muslim and Pakistan
and saying half of what I'm saying on
this show I would have a life expectancy
of about five hours and that is a that
is a political and human rights reality
that every liberal who's using this term
Islamophobia is disregarding and not at
their peril at the peril of all the
people who are not being helped by by
Westerners who could help you know and
non-muslims who could help and what
non-muslims can do is help in whatever
way possible to make criticism of
theocracy in the in the Muslim world
safe to do so yet no I don't generalize
and I think of course there are millions
and millions of Muslims who do not take
the barbaric passages in the Quran the
hadith seriously and who are not wanting
to kill apostates and don't want to
throw gays from rooftops and those are
not the people I'm talking about I mean
or if I'm ever talking about them in my
criticism of religion I'm talking about
them in the same spirit that I talked
about you know Reform Jews or non
doctrinaire Christians who are who are
not a real threat to anybody who but who
or but who may be bending public policy
around in ways we don't like sure the
problem with many of those Muslims is
they don't want their religion
criticized at all and they don't want
any link between its core tenants code
tenants around jihad and paradise and
martyrdom spelled out with the you know
in terms of it's it's the way it's
generating the kinds of violence and
intolerance we're seeing in the world
today so and so far if you're going to
defend your religion by saying Islam is
a religion of peace and the Islamic
state has nothing to do with Islam
you're being intellectually dishonest in
that kind of denial of obvious realities
now is I think you know irresponsible
and dangerous yeah just to close the
door to notions of racism and bigotry
against Muslims as people I think I
think the the apostates the
intellectuals the the women
the gaze of the Muslim world are the
most the most important people in the
world right now if we could give green
cards to every real secularist in the
Muslim world I think they should just
get to the front of the line I mean
these are these are the people who need
to be empowered and so that's I mean the
irony is that they you know if they
could leave the Muslim world they the
Muslim world needs them right so maybe
the best thing to do would be to empower
them in the Muslim world but right
method you know life for these people is
in countries like Pakistan and Bank
Melia Bangladeshi blogger is being
murdered in public by machete-wielding
maniacs and nothing and happens right
it's yeah I mean I so my everything I
say about Islam is a confession of
solidarity with these people and and so
how you get racism out of that or
bigotry against Muslims is people you
know that's you have your better
geometers than I